- I don't think you have a lot, Babon.
He just shook his head.
Babon doesn't have a whole lot.
And honestly, to be very frank,
I think this could be the
best episode of DailyVee ever.
♫ We're unstoppable
Hey guys.
I'm gonna try to figure out
something for today's episode.
Literally the entire day is predicated on
internal meetings that we can't show
so we're trying sit here,
figure it out.
How we're gonna hack it.
Maybe on some of my
drives I'll do some rants.
Talk a state of the union.
Why don't you have the team talk?
You know what we'll do today?
We'll social commentate
on some of the business
things that happening in the world.
(ding)
So why don't you get the team,
look at some of the headlines.
I'll do a little reading
for a quick minute
and I'll give my two cents on
Toys "R" Us going out of business.
So let me just talk to you guys about why
Toys "R" Us filing chapter 11 matters.
Toys "R" Us
did two things over
the last couple decades
that make no sense.
One, very early in the 2000s,
they outsourced themselves to Amazon.
They didn't believe in the internet
17 years ago, so they let
Amazon do their fulfillment
which started people
getting used to buying toys
on the internet through an Amazon world.
But most importantly,
they just didn't innovate.
You know, and when you
don't innovate, you die.
Like you could've made,
Toys "R" Us three years
ago could've created
the National Lego Championships,
and everybody would be--
There was a million--
They could've made slime centers.
They could be killing it right
now with their locations,
but no, they choose
to just like sell toys out of it.
And none of you wanna go there.
First of all, you're gonna go to Walmart
and pick it up for less money anyway,
while you pick up your
groceries and everything else.
And if you even wanna
leave your fuckin' home.
And you don't.
And so you'll go to
Amazon and do it that way,
or buy it from somebody's
YouTube channel link,
or Instagram account.
It's the best example right now
of like how in trouble everybody is
if they fuckin' rest on their laurels.
You know if Toys "R" Us,
the dominant niche retail leader
of a humongous multi-billion
dollar category
is finished,
what do you think is gonna
happen over the next 6 years?
You know classic day of being a CEO of
big fuckin' company.
(murmuring)
Yeah, I've been really in it, right?
Like,
we're fuckin' in it.
We're fuckin' in it.
(mellow music)
That's cool.
What is it?
- It's just new hardware,
probably connect the glasses.
- Connect the glasses?
Glasses that talk?
- Yeah voice and comments.
- You want me to tell everybody
what I think about that?
I like it.
Dude, guys
every single thing is
gonna interact with every
single thing.
Go find a clip right now of
me talking about smart pants.
Everything in the world will be smart.
Your shirt, your pants, your
underwear, your sneakers,
your socks.
That's what I think about smart glasses.
This coffee cup is gonna tell me
that this coffee's cold.
It's gonna give me a
recommendation of a cool coffee
that's gonna automatically order it
through my phone.
It's gonna show up here.
I mean, it's fuckin' all.
- What's going on in Gary's
World, his brand director?
I was pretty impressed with
the Reddit kid's content
that he sent through.
- Yeah it was baller.
♫ I got internship on internship
♫ Inside my resume
I thought we were in the
content business? (laughs)
- They're the same.
Well we've leveled up.
Content business
and now we're just media.
Media conglomerate around one human being.
- Who is that?
- The savage in there.
(group conversing)
(clicking)
- What am a I walking into?
A round table discussion?
- [Man In Front Seat] So
the first part is just you
(audio cuts out)
from home lending plus
CEO
- CEO.
Oh this is more business talk?
- [Man In Front Seat] This was
the follow-up from that talk.
- Yeah, this is good.
We're doing that now?
- [Man In Front Seat] Yep.
- Awesome.
- [Man In Front Seat] So,
we can count on that on
the way out.
Round table, I have no
idea what you're doing.
(laughing)
- I was making a joke that I don't know
what I'm doing until the morning,
when I take first glance at it.
The fact that I don't know what I'm doing
20 minutes before what I'm doing it,
is even a whole nother level.
I just don't know what I'm doing.
Hey kids,
the key to success is not
know what you're doing.
- [Man In Front Seat] Wing it.
- On the fly.
- Okay man.
- Willie Morris.
- Drinks or something soon?
- Yeah, I'd love that.
- Okay.
- Heading into a meeting
with our Chase client.
One of the biggest brands in the world.
Joe Whitmarsh,
long time--
show Joe.
Long time vet at VaynerMedia.
Made that show, Grow Your CEO Life.
800 emails.
1,500 texts.
I think there is just
not enough appreciation
for the amount of volume
of work and effort,
and energy, just energy needed
to sit on top of something
successful.
A lot of people want
these big companies
that you guys all wanna build.
I just wanna make sure
everybody understands
the emotional drainage that
is happening in real time.
Make sure your energy is up.
(mellow music)
Long day.
8:24 p.m., New York.
About to go into two meetings.
I was with clients the whole day.
I don't think you have a whole lot Babon.
He just shook his head.
Babon doesn't have a whole lot.
And honestly to be very frank,
I think this could be the
best episode of DailyVee ever.
Make it short as fuck.
Show it what it is.
It's real simple.
Like
just a lot fuckin' work.
Lot of grinding.
Every day's different.
Not everyday is super fun and glamorous,
even with fuckin' some cool,
up and coming hip hop music.
Some interesting edits.
Some different angles.
Like sometimes YouTube,
it just is what it is, right?
Like,
Babon can only do so much.
You know.
Just fuckin' 15 hours of
fuckin' hustling today.
Client, client, client,
client, client, client, client,
you know?
Just what it was.
Just what it is.
That's actually what it is
a whole lot of the time.
Luckily--
I love that you're, right?
That all it really fuckin' is.
Like we find our, you know
the speeches help.
The traveling helps, but like.
- [Babon] It's kind of boring though.
- Yeah man, the whole
thing's fuckin' boring.
You know, I'm a little bit
entertaining as a personality
and I'm putting out, I'm
showing and talking about
stuff that matters to people.
If they're really paying attention,
watch what I do, not what I say.
We, you know.
I think the thing that's not boring is
it's fuckin' real,
it's the fuckin' truth.
And so for every one of you
trying to get yours
in your genre,
in your world,
your way,
no special effects are more
powerful than a true story.
The story always wins.
(mellow music)
Yeah man, the whole
thing's fuckin' boring.